el sonido de explosiones lejanas resuene
en el centro de kiev
a medida que amanece las sirenas
antiaéreas de la capital ucraniana
sustituyen los estallidos
mientras Rusia inicia su ofensiva
militar en Ucrania los ciudadanos de
kiev se apresuran a salir de la ciudad
ya sea por carretera o por tren
porque vas al metro
salvar nuestras vidas
una de las primeras ciudades afectadas
es hardcore cerca de la frontera rusa el
sonido de los bombardeos resuena está
bien entrada a la mañana
me he despertado y he oído una serie de
disparos he salido corriendo al balcón y
me he dado cuenta de que no eran fuegos
artificiales eran explosiones viumo en
el Horizonte
el humo sale de un aeropuerto militar
alcanzado por los proyectiles en la
ciudad portuaria de Mario Paul a menos
de 20 km de las trincheras más cercanas
en la región Oriental del Don vas la
acumulación de tropas es difícil de
ignorar los residentes hacen Cola en un
cajero automático mientras empieza a
sentir la prisa por abandonar lo que
pronto será una zona de guerra